all right we turn out of the showdown
between wall street and home traders
over game stock stop that has taken a
dramatic new turn
a trading frenzy intensified yesterday
when the popular trading app
robin hood blocked traders from buying
the retailer stock
that move led to cries the company was
improperly protecting
big traders from losing money to
small-time investors
investors vladimir duche is here with
the latest flag good morning
good morning retail investors are
allowed this morning to buy shares of
those stocks in limited quantity but
many are still outraged over what they
feel is unfair interference
they claim it caused them to miss their
chance to buy in
what began as a social media skirmish
has exploded into a debate in washington
and
on wall street over who makes the rules
and whom they apply to
they call themselves robin hood which i
mean
to take from the rich and give to the
poor they did the exact opposite today
thursday discount online brokerage robin
hood barred users without warning from
buying new shares of gamestop
in recent weeks small investors driven
by momentum on the reddit forum wall
street bets
have sent the stock price soaring by
over 1600 percent
critics including barstool sports
founder dave portnoy who himself
owns gamestop stock allege the brokerage
did it to protect hedge funds
and other wall street institutions
hoping to profit by
betting against the company what if they
say look uh
the valuations of the stock where the
price was it just wasn't sustainable
nobody is going to debate that the price
of gamestop or any of these others were
fair
market valuation everyone has skin in
the game
but now when the retail guy the everyday
jimmy and joe
when they're winning suddenly the rules
change but robin hood ceo vlad tenev
denied any foul play
saying the move was aimed at protecting
the firm and its users
we absolutely did not do this at the
direction
of any market maker or hedge fund
or anyone we route to or other market
participants
lawmakers from democrat alexandria
ocasio-cortez
to republican ted cruz have blasted
robin hood over its gamestop trading
freeze
i think the forces that regulate the
market whether congress
more importantly the sec in the
exchanges need to understand
these dynamics jacob frankel is a former
sec lawyer
he doesn't think new regulations are
required but does believe the industry
must adjust to its new reality what does
it mean
for the future of trading it means
that the sec and the markets in some
respects need to recalibrate
the markets are looking at something
they've never experienced before
robin hood says it will continue to
monitor the situation and make
adjustments as needed faced with a high
volume of trades and demands for cash
the company announced last night
that it raised more than a billion
dollars from existing investors
which it called a strong sign of
confidence gail it's quite a story thank
you vlad